for loops are similar to while loops but
check for conditions in a slightly
different way we have an initialization
value a condition that gets checked on
every iteration of the loop and a
mutator that increments or decrements
the initialization value so for example
in this for loop we initialize an
increment or I by using the same var
syntax we've been using all of course
then we set the condition I less than
nine using an operator that we saw
before and then we increment I by one by
adding I plus plus for every trip
through the loop we're going to console
dot log I you know what before I tell
you what's going to happen I think this
is something you can figure out on your
own make a prediction
what will the result of this code be
type your answer in this box once you've
made your prediction type this code into
your browser's console and press Enter
to watch what happens is it what you
expected when you try to type this for
loop into your browser don't worry about
putting everything on separate lines you
can type all this out on one line